action amy est une journaliste qui écrit
pour un magazine snuff lorsque vous écrivez
un article et que quelqu'un dit que quelque chose
n'est pas enregistré, vous pouvez toujours l'utiliser non
vous ne pouvez pas nous avons la grande Vanessa
Bayer Nikki Je veux que vous recherchiez
si l'ail fait  le sperme a un goût
différent oh euh comment suis-je censé
vous remercier allez-y vous m'inspirez nous
avons le grand Ezra Miller vos cheveux étaient
si longs au moins vous pouvez le sentir dans
vos mains avec votre action c'est vrai
ne prenez pas le  les cheveux mis à la
poubelle, nous avons Randall Park et Jonathan
Glazer et il semble qu'à chaque fois qu'ils
font une nouvelle blague, Amy pou les filles prennent avez-
vous déjà vu un article sur
un fétiche où les gars aiment se masturber
pour des combats de hockey ce n'est pas une chose  pas
une chose alors pourquoi ça marche pour moi je vais
manquer une promotion pour toi Amy peux-tu
gérer leur charge Amy je peux gérer toutes
leurs charges voyons tilda swinton je
voulais travailler avec elle depuis longtemps
je l'ai rencontrée un  plusieurs fois depuis qu'elle a
dit  nous devrions faire quelque chose et j'ai toujours
pensé qu'elle mentait mais elle s'est présentée
pour jouer le patron de Diana Amy où vous
saurez où est le vrai tueur bien je l'ai déjà
fait en privé il y a
des gens qui se promènent comme si c'était mon
quartier  maintenant